welcome to this video against Muhammad
Muhammad a fear that's probably the
right way to pronounce that okay Matt
probably not the right way but I
probably could have butchered it more
okay what is he doing in the color
opening yeah that's let's solid care not
doing anything fancy here just
developing stuff yeah he's not very high
rated but I have a bad score high as the
sky have a point out of three games yeah
is this a moment for Bishop takes age
three or not it's close that's close I
need a little bit more I think to have
this working Bishop O'Ree Queen g3 check
that's one of the ideas of the setup
that I that I went for but if you place
ok this is this is obviously closing
closing the diagonal so i don't i don't
have this idea anymore I no problem
see you feels like a fairly normal
position
I didn't think about that with that much
hmm ok it's nothing serious though I
guess
quinta six could have taken down age
three I don't think so maybe I could
have taken them
yeah that looks like an fairly normal I
QP position out of go Bishop f to Queen
f 2 nite f2 rookie 7
Bishop f2 Queen f2 who calculates this
kind of thing who's playing night see to
allowing this on f2 word that's really a
funny way to play but maybe it's just
good it's very much possible so Bishop
have to hunker in F 2 nite f2 rookie 7y
now take the 319 i don'ti don't see any
of that okay Queen f 2 nite F to take d3
and I take everything here right what is
what is the point take this
okie seven I mean maybe can take that
one
ok
and somehow this is playable g3 night h2
even that yes maybe low key to take
sloop see two tix on g5 that's not
really convincing check on H 2 O king
brooke check at the end you will take
them the end you will take that one on
f7
check yeah anyway what what else is
there is there this move okay I thought
King age too but it's probably probably
no huge difference
Jack I see no way to to win this really
let's do this no I wanted to play hmm I
want you to play something else actually
forgot what it was now can I just take
stuff maybe can invade with this King
there
I should probably come with a six rank
though that is not coming in there with
the king
check yeah okay can jail he can draw it
will oh of course check check check
check game drawn Jeff what a weird game
what a weird game I really don't can get
all you can get to this move just
allowing everything on f2 but ok it's
nothing special she just calculated it
takes takes takes and somehow this is
still playable I went yeah that is all
fine check I don't know what I actually
wanted to play them with a g4 or
something yeah there's there's no way to
even this is of course a draw check can
check nothing nothing I can do I wanted
to briefly check this Bishop h3
possibility h3 is a little innocent move
but sometimes you can really do that
it's just this thing here check I wasn't
I wasn't maybe maybe it's not ridiculous
it's definitely not 494
computer wants to defend with this oh
then this little move interesting yeah
this is embarrassing so this has to be
played to this this funny typically we
add computer line at the end it says
equal okay how a strange game in any
case well thanks for watching